[Music]
chess lebanese salah
2120 let's go e4 and we are white again
i've been white
in four games in our own speaking of the
french he's done it
so i am going to play what i actually
normally play against the french
which is called the tarash defense i
will talk about this move
after the game and he takes on e4 that
is the rubinstein french
it's what andrew tang plays it's a very
solid opening
uh it's not like that good and knight f6
is considered to be quite inaccurate and
the reason why
is because he has to ruin his pawn
structure very early
now there's nothing that we need to do
specifically here we'll just develop our
pieces knight f3
and let's think about where we want this
bishop to go
where should we deploy this bishop
the move is bishop d3 and what we're
going to try to do
is root out this bishop on b7 this is
his only strong piece
so if you're thinking ahead if you want
to get rid of this bishop or at least
contest it
what idea can you guys come up with that
may allow us to do that
because his bishop can can get very
annoying particularly if i
put castle and f w nietzsche and your
quick queen e2 is the move
not only are we insinuating well we can
play bishop a6
but mainly i was thinking of bishop e4
and um well
the question is sorry can we play bishop
a6 let's calculate a little bit bishop
a6
if he takes and then he takes on d4
who can visualize that position and tell
me what move white has
in that situation bishop a6
captures captures and then he captures
on d4 that's a type 1 undefended piece
which we can fork by playing queen a4 i
will illustrate that obviously
after the game in the interest of time i
i have to make some moves
so we actually can trade the bishops
what happens if i do it anyway at this
level
you got to start questioning basic
assumptions right and you got to start
calculating variations more intensively
that's just part of the part of the
process you can't reason your way
out of everything uh sometimes you need
to just plunge in get your hands dirty
and and that becomes increasingly the
case the higher rated you get
so he's gonna have to decide what to do
about this trade
uh he can take the bishop but that would
get my queen to a nice spot
he could support the bishop on b7 and i
would definitely take it and then i
could potentially strike
by playing d5 using the pin so we'll see
what he what he decides to do he's
thinking
no plenty of people mentioned queen
eight four oh crap
i saw this move now he came up with a
very clever idea
he's winning upon he's switched up the
move order of what he's done
and he wins upon i did see this
and why did we go for this anyway
because look at his position first look
at his king his king is caught in the
center
the board is wide open so i made a
judgment call
that my compensation what i have in
exchange for the
pawn here is going to be sufficiently
weighted to warrant giving up upon maybe
i'm wrong
that's a pretty risky judgment call to
make but a pond is not such a big deal
to where we can never come back
even if this turns out to backfire he
can't he cannot castle right because
we're
stopped even if he could even if he
finds a way to castle short which is
quite likely
his king is still going to be weak there
and that's what the battle is going to
revolve around
okay um what should we do here
how should we and we should definitely
yeah so we should absolutely continue
our development
we can do that in several different ways
we call it bishop f4
or yeah definitely followed by rook d1
that part is obvious
um but i actually like the idea of
getting the bishop out to f4 a little
bit of a more active square
and if he goes bishop d6 i kind of like
the standoff
that happens between the bishops i kind
of like it
because that adds some spice to the
position
and the other thing which may look
irrelevant is that if he ever castles
short
keeping the bishop on f4 will keep the
avenue open for a potential rook lift
we had the bishop on e3 uh we wouldn't
have been able to lift the rook it goes
rook a
rook to g8 potentially sort of
pressuring this pawn
okay so this guy is very good obviously
uh
and now we are going to go
well let's see well let's go work do you
want any i don't see
the danger yet he's going to go here and
then we're going
defend the pawn on g2 defend against
checkmate
okay
no i don't believe we're in the range of
my rating right now um
if you add a thousand points then we
won't be so how should we defend this
pawn
without making additional weaknesses to
our king side
so f3 is possible but that opens up a
diagonal i actually kind of like
f3 though uh but that's yeah let's go
bishop g3 let's uh let's drop the bishop
back intercepting his rook
well i've been sweating and i'm gonna
lose eventually because i'm also talking
through the games
which does you know it does make me a
little bit slower now we need to lift
our rook up
in order again to add some some tobasco
sauce here there's two ideas with this
move
the first is potentially to go to c3 the
second of course is to double rooks
using this
main artery toward his king so we're
trying to do here is deploy all of our
pieces
and and get the attack started against
black's king which is now permanently
stranded in the center he's moved his
rook
which means he's forfeited his right to
castle
aren't we just losing more puns well
we're sacrificing them right i don't
care about pawns here i'm
keeping my eyes on the prize uh so
we actually could play fg and open up
the f file
but i'm gonna play hg here because fg
also creates
some weaknesses in the range of our king
and i wanna keep my king
very safe i don't wanna have to worry
about that
okay rook g5 lifting up his own rook
that's an incredibly good move actually
and um what is he threatening here and
what should we do about it
this is a a brilliant move
so he wants rook a5 trapping our queen
which means that we need to play a
a move that that has that in mind so
let's go rook to f3
to evacuate or offer the queen in
evacuation zone
2 to d3 for example and then let's see
what he ends
rook c3 would have led to rook c5 again
after we have a lot to discuss here
and we'll look at some of the concrete
variations after the game
um and um
okay rook a5 now according to plan we
drop our queen to d3 we attack two pawns
at once
but he's i think he's foreseen this
yeah he has so now well there's a couple
things we can do right
first thing we need to ask ourselves do
have we deployed the rest of our pieces
and the answer is no right uh rook to e1
would create the pin against the pawn on
e6 deploying the last rook
i realize that i'm leaving all these
pawns hanging for most of the game
there are tactical reasons why he can't
really capture them
and even if he could if i sacrifice two
more pawns that's not really going to
change the
makeup of the situation i'm going for
checkmate here
um so let's okay we got to drop our
queen
and i keep tempting him into capturing
more pawns
uh which i think is actually going to be
good for me let's see if he doesn't
he he's just incredibly good um
extremely underrated but i think he's
legit
so we're gonna go queen g5 here
involving the queen and trying to
penetrate to g8
okay let's see what he does
okay rook uh queen to d2 what should we
do how do we avoid
the queen trade and if you give a check
on g8 then you allow king e7
so what we can do is we can intercept
good job nanuka we can intercept the
queen by playing rook to e3
and we're actually threatening something
very devilish right now
we have a quite a pretty threat and
let's see if he sees it
he does which does not surprise me
but um just because i kind of
talked smack about puns doesn't mean
that we don't want to take them if
they're lying around on the table and
well here they are we can take on h7
and that queen can swing back to h4 and
continue the attack we're just trying to
continue
poking and prodding and uh and hoping
eventually that something will give
attacking is is is is an art not a
science
and now i'm going to deploy my queen to
g maybe come to c8 you know i'm trying
to poke and pride
get him low on time that's all very
viable okay that's another very good
move by him let's give it a check
yeah he's outplaying me now let's drop
the queen back the worst thing that we
can do
here is trade queens that is the
absolute
last resort right we don't want to trade
queens
okay so let's go check
and if he goes queen f6 what we're gonna
do and
wow he spots that as well so here just
give me a moment let me focus
yeah this is my territory but this guy
is actually
unbelievably strong
good shotgun i'm winning yeah so
okay good game um yeah that guy was
really good
really really good and um
i have to say yeah his defense was
absolutely
stellar
well yeah at some point i i have to step
step up
um and i don't think i was ever
losing per se but i i did not expect the
attack to go as poorly as
it did so let's deconstruct it and um
and then we'll end there
thank you for the hundred bits of
lasagna yeah let me check i'm just
curious
very quickly what yeah i'll check the
percentages uh probably uh we i mean i
played terribly but
yeah so it's um 90 for me to 88
for him um so we both played pretty well
i mean
yeah okay a lot of people are underrated
at this at this level so anyways
now knight f6 is not considered to be
the best move now
um knight d7 is
is the best and uh now knight f6
so the reason is you want to be able to
recapture with the knight
uh not not the pawn or the queen both of
which contain
uh their drawbacks right if if queen
takes f6
then we saw this in one of our games
right we all of a sudden trap the queen
with oh 1000 bits thank you innovative
and the queen is no square so that
happened in an earlier game we played
but he took with a pawn which does have
the benefit of opening up the g-file we
saw that he later exploited that
oh fischer sub your your chest lebanese
saw nice
so basically i guess the bishop a6 was
wrong
um and what should we have done instead
in retrospect if we wanted to defend
this pawn
what should we have done what should we
have done
c3 right creating the pawn chain and
then patiently
either bishop a6 or bishop b4 now i saw
this move
uh and the idea is you interpose the
move or remember if he would have taken
here first and here second
we would have gone queen to a4 forking
the knight and the king
so he decides to take your first of
course we cannot take the bishop because
he takes the queen now he takes on a6
intermediate move
and queen takes part so i had to
calculate it up to this position and
concluded
that because his king is so stranded in
the center um
white white is in good shape but i was
wrong i made the wrong judgment call
and there was a very specific reason
that i made the wrong judgment call my
mistake and i'm learning from this
i i failed to notice one very specific
thing
i overestimated the role of the d-file
i thought that i would be able to get a
rook to d1 quickly and win the game
what did i miss what did i not what did
i fail to sort of account for fully
what defensive idea not the counter play
on the g file that wasn't dangerous
the idea of bishop d6 that bishop on d6
is solid as a rock
and once he puts it there it shuts off
that main artery to his king
and the fact that he's got bad pawns and
the fact that he's in castle just isn't
that important
so what i tried to do now is bring as
many pieces into the game as possible
and once the bishops were traded that's
just not something i anticipated he
brought his pieces out
the d file stopped being relevant he
started b he started just controlling it
now one thing i wanted to point out
right at no point could he have taken
the pawn with impunity
queen takes c2 allows rook to c3
and now i take on c sub uh and and he's
under devastate so i just
wrote g5 is the only way to preserve the
advantage that's a brilliant move
so i go rook f3 to evacuate my queen
rookie want to deploy my rook and
here although what black is two pawns up
objectively black is probably winning
the king is still under some fire queen
takes f5 by the way
looks tempting because the pawn can't
take the game but remember he's got a
rook there
that's guarding that squad that spot
okay so queen g5
rook fe3 of course uh avoiding the queen
trade now could somebody spot my threat
i i had a very very pretty idea and
let's say he takes on a2
who can spy the tactical concept here
[Music]
yeah you guys all are all sharp rook
takes e6
he's correct now we sacked the rope to
open up the king of king d7
then we win the queen and the rook if
king f7
this is checkmate and if king f8
this is the nice part um it we're
actually it's the mate is not that easy
here but we give a check
another check and made on e6 kind of
pretty line
so typical sacrifice but nonetheless uh
salah was on on top of that and we won
one of the pawns back he got it back
and eventually we got this kind of
position where black's got three
connected pass pawns all of them extra
extra but i think salah in time pressure
he allowed
some activity so what should black have
done i think what black should have done
here is try to trade
pieces as quickly as possible so in
light of that what move would you
propose
for black hair esteban gc
thing for the sub or k1
yeah it kills it kills the play because
the reality is black can win with rook
d1 here and just go for the checkmate
but even if you didn't do that
even if you drop the queen back that's
also fine because you
eliminate all the counter play but in in
time pressure he allowed queen f6 and
now things get very complicated after
rook c3 are no longer worse
king c8 tucking the king behind the pawn
shell was the last chance to preserve
a big advantage for black but after king
c6 i drive
the king into the open and then i slice
off
the uh you know the defense of the rook
on c6 winning winning a full oh
i missed made in one actually that's
pretty funny i i missed made in one with
queen takes a seven i basically
pre-moved in my head queen takes c6
so not my best performance i'd say but
uh not to take a single thing away from
chess lebanese sally played like a
monster
um he played like a monster and um
he you know he did a very good job
fearlessly going for that position which
i'd evaluated as
it's better for white but um
you know that was a key mistake and what
what i take away from this game is not
to
you know to spend longer evaluating the
compensation i think i have right try to
recognize things like a square on d6
which would shut down the main source of
counter play
can i square rook 81 was preferred of
her rook after one well
because now if you go rook after one i
always advocate to think about the other
rook
now the rook on a1 is no prospect
whereas if you go rook 81
then this other rook could sit on e1 and
x-ray the king
um why did you go bishop f4 instead of
bishop well by that point
i want him to play e5 because that
pushes out a pawn that creates
weaknesses
and uh that also creates a hook and i
could attack that hook by playing f4 in
the future so i want him to send forward
his pawns
um queen b7 but what is that really i
guess i should have done this
but he can go rook d8 and i wasn't in
the mentality to like
try to win back the pawn i thought that
i have sufficient compensation for it
oh after this yeah but queen b7 queen d5
at the very least he's got forcing an
end game or again you can go rook d8 and
if you play queen c7 i guess he can
capture and win back the pawn with rook
c8 so to me this seemed
a little bit too um to vanilla
okay so since your queen dominates the
queen side
yeah but harvey the problem with that
was that it would be too slow right
that's that's a good idea in theory
but it's it's just not gonna work out
because the thing is
one two three four i mean there's like
five six moves and black has these ideas
of opening up the g file
it's just not gonna be not gonna be
swift enough if that makes sense okay
but um by and large
that's how the game went good job to my
opponent and
our first 31 2100 and uh he gave me a
run for my money for sure
here we go lemon buffalo
okay dolphin dobrin 357 so let's play an
accelerated dragon
okay so bishops bishop f3 oh sorry
bishop c4 and knight f3
uh we've tackled this many times at a at
a lower level it's not as common at a
2000 level
uh and basically we already know
that black's main strategy is to prepare
the move d5 now queen e2 is a very
subtle move
he's preemptively pinning the king so d5
would would meet with e takes d5
uh and that would not be a good result
because then i wouldn't be able to
capture back because of the pit
uh but we shouldn't panic here and we
should be very careful about playing
bishop e7 because that would allow him
to clamp down on us with e5
so let's play d6 in order to take the
sting out of e5
and now just continue developing
normally that doesn't mean we won't play
d5
we still might play d5 and it's okay to
lose the tempo
because white hasn't placed his pieces
in a very threatening way
so d5 here would be a very sensible move
in fact
we're gonna play it no problem playing
this move
uh e x c x thank you for the prime now
what should we do
who can tell me a good idea in this
position
how should we go about playing this
position
so knight a5 is possible we can go after
the bishop
um we could also go b5 and expand
on the uh queen side but i want to make
a move
that a lot of people would look at and
kind of roll their eyes i'm gonna play
rookie a thank you jackie
why am i playing rookie and i'm going to
explain the the sort of the psychology
behind this after the game
but the mover kid is sort of a general
improving move i'm kind of waiting for
my opponent to
to put his cards on the table before
devising a strategy now here's the thing
we ask ourselves what the drawback of
the move c3 is
and what i'm seeing is that it weakens
the d3 pawn but can we get to that pawn
well that pawn is on a light square how
can we deploy this bishop
to aim ourselves at that point who can
tell me very quickly before i make this
move
yeah b6 bishop a6 that's right
okay knight g5 i guess
he wants knight h3 i guess we can chase
that knight away first
let's get it out of there and then play
bishop a6
now if he goes okay so he goes f3 what
should we do now that this is already a
very serious mistake
he doesn't fully appreciate the idea of
our previous move
so we now have all of these sources of
attack
on the pawn so all we have to do no not
c4 remember
keep your eyes on the prize don't
confuse uh exploiting weakness with
elimination
actually helps him d take c4 is the is
the move this is a very instructive
moment
and now what should we take the pawn
with the queen of the bishop
and this is a good example of not
falling for general principles but here
prioritizing concreteness we take with
the bishop
uh because we pin his queen to his rook
we win the exchange and upon our
position is now winning
but we need to play swiftly and
precisely to not let him back into the
game so we saw our
plan worked like a charm bishop takes f1
now after king takes f1 here's what i
see the knight is a type
2 undefended piece which means it's only
defended by one other piece that's the
bishop
how can we use that factor to deploy
and further activate some of our pieces
so knight e5 would be the obvious move
but what i like here is c4
in order to redeploy this bishop to c5 i
think i've said deploy too many okay
this guy
has completely fallen to pieces uh has
completely fallen no he he plays like it
he's
he's not like provisional or anything he
actually does
does uh keep his rating i don't know
what what the deal is i think he just
panicked
okay so we're just going to trade
bishops here we're going to complete our
idea bishop c5
and now i'm going to do something kind
of fancy which way would you guys take
which just out of curiosity who thinks
that they can decode
what i want to do here okay guys we can
move on from the fact that he's playing
badly there's there's nothing i can do
about it
pawn to open up the b file love the
mentality everybody is
saying it now no problem how should we
unpin ourselves
rook edith c8 remember that the best way
to solve a p pin
is to defend the pinned piece with what
i call the penny
you know there's like the uh you in
english you add the double e
uh to refer to something that's on the
receiving end of something so then the
knight is the pinned piece
and i found that there was no word for
the rook so i've developed this word
penny
the work is the penny p
i n e e p
all right of course the penny is
okay this is winning very exquisite yes
exquisite
the penny pasta yeah i'm gonna get the
peanut paste and i'll see the
that
[Music]
okay i think this man can resign
this move had an idea what is the idea
of this move
who can tell me i didn't just play this
move to
screw around what was the idea of this
move
stop knight before so you can play c4
bingo
excellent you guys are on top of things
can we go rook c5
no because of 97 great count
of course we can we're still completely
winning
but there is no need to give up and
that's something i want to make very
clear i see a lot of people getting in
trouble because of this
now even at a high level i sometimes see
people go up a lot of material and then
they'll just start
arbitrarily giving up material to trade
more pieces
and that's fine we've done that many
times i've emphasized
the importance of that idea but you
don't want to take it too far it's okay
to give up a pawn
uh if you're up a queen it's a give up
an exchange if you're up a rook
but only if it's necessary you don't
want to do that if it's not strictly
necessary
because what often ends up happening is
you're not left with
that much extra material and you
overestimate its value
and i've seen people get in trouble
because of that so um i just wanted to
emphasize that point okay we can
actually pre-move this
he has no way to defend against the
checkmate unless he gives me this check
yeah oh my god
i should have moved the rook it doesn't
matter okay let's just prolongs the game
yeah i'm sorry only because he's not
resigning
uh i have no problem with this but okay
finally he resigns
finally he resigns okay sorry that was
the wrong game
okay so what happens here
now i've shown you guys
why a move like bishop e7 is bad and
i've even shown you guys
the stem game where this was played
and black got himself in very serious
trouble to
to remind you guys there was a very
beautiful game played by t
ground petrossian which served as kind
of the classic illustration of
why this particular structure is
very bad now conceptually the reason
it's bad is black white is this clamp
on the d6 square why does this clamp on
the d6 square and that clamp is actually
quite a bit more unpleasant than it
appears i froze my computer's frozen
the game that really convinced people of
how bad this type of thing
is is petrosian against pacman that was
a different opening
but guess what black played here what
move did black play here black castles
and what did he allow who can tell me
what move and castles was wrong black
should have played
d6 this will be familiar to us in a
moment
luneck bachmann was a gm but he allowed
e5 he didn't understand why this was bad
it is true that black breaks through the
clamp with d6 but now black has all of
these weaknesses that are remaining as a
result of it
petrosian goes after them and he won the
game very easily and he wanted playing
on these dark squares
it's very important to recognize this if
you're a sicilian player
be very careful about allowing that
that's why we played the move d6
okay so d6 bishop e7 castles castles and
here d5
now i want to make it very clear that
some people
would not play a move like this because
we've already played d6 and they
wouldn't want to lose a tempo tempi
are relative okay a tempo is not
does not have intrinsic value um and
because our opponent is playing so
passively we can afford
to spend another tempo on d5 you don't
owe it to anybody to like
try to be consistent in a certain way so
c3 what is the drawback
weakens the pawn how do we exploit it
deploying our bishop to a6
and of course he played f3 now what
should he have done here he probably
should have played e5 honestly
and and at least closed off the avenue
to the pawn and here you know
we have a lot of things we can do we can
go b5 and and d4 or c4
i like black's position but it's it's
obviously very much a game
and of course after f3 he gives up
everything here and now c4
right exploiting the type 2 undefended
piece knight a5 would have been a little
less effective because of bishop c2
so oh why rookie yeah yeah yeah i wrote
this down i
even wrote this down why did i play
rookie 8 what is the psychology now
let me explain this from two angles now
first of all what does rookie a do
what what exactly does this move
accomplish well it accomplishes a couple
of things right it
x-rays the queen so if he ever takes you
guys can see why the rook would be
meaningful here
in addition it creates the little f8
square for the bishop that could be very
helpful in a variety of positions or
even the night
you know that could be helpful in a
variety of positions
and above all else i'm basically waiting
for my opponent to show me
how he's going to position his pieces
this is what's called a healthy waiting
move
it's a useful waiting move but it still
is kind of a waiting move
and i didn't want to commit to a
particular strategy for example if i'd
gone b5
he had a nasty move a4 cutting into my
my little pawn majority on the queen
side so
it's this sort of game of cat mouse
where i'm almost waiting for him to
commit to a plan
so that i can choose a plan in
accordance with that i think something
like c4 was objectively probably
strongest
but i wanted to illustrate this concept
to you guys what's an unhealthy
weighting move
h6 h6 would be an unhealthy waiting move
because it would create a weakness on
the king's side a hook
that my opponent can then use it would
in effect backfire
by helping him make a plan b6
yeah b6 would be fine but i wouldn't
really see a point in putting the bishop
on a6 if this pawn weren't weak
okay so yeah so e5 he could have done
and that closes the position up but now
black can try to attack on the queen
side and i can position my bishop to f8
or even knight f8 knight g6 does that
make sense to everybody
so don't take this too far okay you
should only do this if you're quite sure
that you have
the time for this you can afford it but
i think this was a good time to
illustrate the concept of a healthy
waiting move let's continue
you